let's now get some practice with
separable differential equations so
let's say after the differential
equation the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to 2y squared and
let's say that the graph of a particular
solution to this the graph of a
particular solution passes through the
point 1 comma negative 1 so my question
to you is what is Y what is y when X is
equal to 3 for this particular solution
so the particular solution to the
differential equation that passes
through the point 1 comma negative 1
what is y when X is equal to 3 and I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to work through it on your own so I'm
assuming you had a go at it and the key
with a separable differential equation
and that's a big clue that even calling
it a separate little trash equation is
that you separate the X's from the Y's
or all the X's and the DX is from the
Y's and dys so how do you do that here
well what I could let me just rewrite it
so it's going to be dy/dx is equal to 2y
squared is equal to 2y equal to 2y
squared let's see we can multiply both
sides by DX and let's see so then we're
going to have that cancels with that if
we treat it is it just a value or as a
variable we're going to have dy is equal
to 2y squared DX well we're not quite
done yet we get this 2y squared on the
left hand side so we can divide both
sides by 2y squared so if we divide both
sides by 2y squared - y squared the left
hand side we could rewrite this as 1/2 Y
to the negative 2 power is going to be
equal to dy let me D Y is equal to DX
and now we can integrate both sides so
we can integrate both sides let me get
myself a little bit more space and so
what is
is what is this left-hand side going to
be well we increment the exponent and
then divide by that value so Y to the
negative 2 if you increment its Y to the
negative 1 and then divide by negative 1
so this is going to be negative 1/2 y to
the negative 1 power and we could do a
plus C like we did in the previous video
but we're gonna have a plus C on both
sides and you could subtract or you know
we have different arbitrary constants on
both sides and you could subtract them
from each other so I'm just going to
write the constant only on one side so
you have that is equal to well if I
integrate just DX that's just going to
give me X that's just going to give me X
so this right over here is X and of
course I can have a plus C over there
and if I want I can I can solve for y if
I multiply let's see I can multiply both
sides by negative 2 and then I'm going
to have the left-hand side you're just
going to have Y to the negative 1 or 1
over Y is equal to if I multiply the
right-hand side times negative 2 I'm
going to have negative 2 times X plus
well it's some arbitrary constant it's
still going it's going to be negative 2
times this arbitrary constant but I
could still just call it some arbitrary
constant and then if we want we can take
the reciprocal of both sides and so we
will get Y is equal to is equal to 1
over negative 2x plus C and now we can
use we can use the information they gave
us right over here the fact that our
particular solution needs to go through
this point to solve for C so when X is
negative 1 so when X is negative 1 or
sorry when X is 1 when X is 1 Y is
negative 1 so we get negative 1 is equal
to 1 over negative 2 plus C or we could
say C minus 2 we could multiply both
sides times C minus 2
if then we will get actually let me just
scroll down a little bit so if you
multiply both sides times C minus 2
negative 1 times C minus 2 is going to
be negative C plus 2 or 2 minus C is
equal to 1 all I did is I multiplied C
minus 2 times both sides and then let's
see I can subtract 2 from both sides so
negative C is equal to negative 1 and
then if I multiply both sides by
negative 1 we get C is equal to 1 so our
particular solution is y is equal to 1
over negative 2x plus plus 1 and we are
almost done they didn't just ask for we
didn't just ask for the particular
solution we asked what is y when X is
equal to 3 so Y is going to be equal to
1 over 3 times negative 2 is negative 6
plus 1 which is equal to negative is
going to be equal to 1 over negative 5
or negative 1/5 and we are done